Hallo, guten Tag, mein Name ist Satiji. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig
und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen. Bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid oder
fragen Sie nach, wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, ja, Hauptsache jemand guckt nach mir.
Jetzt bräuchte ich ein paar persönliche Daten von Ihnen. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Werner Kaiser. Könnten Sie bitte Ihren V- und Nachnamen buchstäbieren?
Ja, Werner W-E-R-N-E-R und Kaiser wie der König K-A-I-S-E-R.
Herr Kaiser, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 74.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 9.3.1952.
Am 3.3.1952.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich war mal 1,81. Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht bin ich ein bisschen kleiner inzwischen.
Wie viel wiegen Sie aktuell?
So 90 Kilo ungefähr.
Vielen Dank. Was für ein heutiger Tag, Herr Kaiser? Was ist Ihr Beschwerden?
Ich habe so dollen Husten und den habe ich jetzt schon richtig lange.
Ich nehme auch schon immer wieder komischen Hustensaft, alles was man so kriegen kann in der Apotheke.
Aber es wird also immer schlechter.
Inzwischen habe ich auch das Gefühl, dass mir das hier oben im Brustkorb so weh tut beim Husten.
Und was auch wirklich ein bisschen eklig ist, ich habe immer so weißen schaumigen Kram, der so rauskommt.
Ich muss immer wieder ausspucken gehen.
Und ja, das ist ein bisschen unangenehm.
Ich kann Sie gut verstehen. Es tut mir leid, dass Sie so Schwerden haben. Seit wann haben Sie Husten?
Seit langeren Jahren haben Sie gesagt.
Nein, nicht seit vielen Jahren. Ja gut, ich rauche natürlich und so ein bisschen Husten hat man ja immer mal.
Aber dass das jetzt so schlimm ist, ich würde sagen, das ist jetzt ein Vierteljahr, also drei Monate.
Also das ganze Frühjahr über hußte ich schon und hußte und hußte und es wird überhaupt nicht besser.
Wurde bei Ihnen eine bestimmte Diagnose gestellt? Zum Beispiel Asthma oder bekannte Allergie?
Ja, also ich habe eine Allergie auf Hausstaub, ja.
Aber eigentlich passen Wetter zu Hause auch ziemlich gut auf.
Und also eigentlich dürfte dann jetzt kein Auslöser dafür sein.
Sie haben ja schon gesagt, dass Sie Brustschmerzen haben.
Ja, das tut richtig weh. Manchmal habe ich auch wirklich das Gefühl, als ob ich fast keine Luft mehr kriege.
Und das ist eben neu. So ein bisschen Husten, das kennt man ja.
Aber dass es jetzt erstens wehtut und dass ich so das Gefühl habe, es fehlt was, ich kriege keine Luft.
Das ist wirklich das, was mir Angst macht und weshalb ich auch gekommen bin.
Und ja, ich muss auch dazu sagen, ich habe einen Bruder und der hat Lungenkrebs.
Und der ist auch schon operiert worden und dem geht es gar nicht gut.
Und jetzt habe ich natürlich, ja, ich gebe zu, ich habe da schon ein bisschen Angst und deswegen bin ich auch gleich zu Ihnen gekommen.
Ok, alles klar. Sie haben Atemnot, habe ich recht?
Ja, aber das ist ziemlich neu, dass das jetzt so schlimm ist, dass ich das Gefühl habe, dass ich keine Luft bekomme, ja.
Seit wann haben Sie Atemnot?
Ja, das ist jetzt erst seit ein paar Tagen.
Ein paar Tage.
Tritt die Atemnot nur bei Bewegung oder bei Belastung oder auf dem Husten?
Ja, beim Husten eigentlich. Beim Husten habe ich dann mit einmal das Gefühl, dass ich keine Luft mehr kriege.
Husten, ok.
Haben Sie im Auswurf ein Blut bemerkt?
Blut? Nee, das ist immer nur so weiß-schleimig.
Ok, alles klar. Haben Sie Halsschmerzen, Schnupfen oder andere Beschwerden?
Nee, also eigentlich so richtig eine Erkältung habe ich nicht.
Gibt es jemanden in Ihrer Umgebung mit ähnlichen Beschwerden?
Nee, also meine Frau hat keinen Husten. Und sonst habe ich ja nicht mehr so viel Kontakte. Ich bin ja Rennner.
Ok, ich verstehe. Ist Ihnen übel oder haben Sie erbrochen?
Nee, nee, so schlimm war es nicht.
Ok, haben Sie Beschwerden langsam oder plötzlich bekommen?
Ja, ich würde sagen, das hat langsam angefangen und ist dann immer schlechter geworden.
Aber jetzt so mit der Atemnot und mit den Schmerzen, das ist jetzt so ein bisschen zusätzlich plötzlich gekommen.
Ok, können Sie bitte die Schmerzen genau beschreiben? Sind Sie dumm drückend oder?
Ich kann das nicht gut beschreiben. Also einmal habe ich so ein Druckgefühl.
Aber ja, wie soll ich sagen? Es brennt auch so ein bisschen beim Husten.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 bis 10 die starken Schmerzen entspricht?
Ja, also die Schmerzen, würde ich sagen, sind jetzt nicht so im Vordergrund, so mehr dieses, dass es so erschöpfend ist.
Und lassen Sie mich überleeren, mehr als 5 ist es nicht. Also so in der Mitte oder vielleicht sogar ein bisschen weniger als die Mitte.
Also so schlimm sind die Schmerzen nicht.
Ok, alles klar. Waren Sie unter saurem Aufstoßen?
Nee, zum Glück habe ich damit keine Probleme.
Haben Sie blauliche Hautfarbe an der Lippen oder Fingerspritzen bemerkt? Blauliche Hautfarbe?
Ist mir eigentlich nicht aufgefallen, aber ich gucke auch nicht so oft. Also ich wüsste jetzt nicht, also blau bin ich nicht geworden.
Ok, haben Sie gegen diese Beschwerden irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe alle möglichen Hustensäfte schon genommen, aber das bringt irgendwie alles nichts.
Könnten Sie bitte wiederholen, was haben Sie genommen?
Ja, ich habe Hustensaft genommen, was man in der Apotheke bekommen kann.
Ok, alles klar. Hat es Ihnen geholfen?
Nee, eben nicht wirklich.
Haben Sie Fieber, Stoffrost?
Nein, nein, nein, ich muss nur husten.
Ok, schwitzen Sie oft in der Nacht?
Nee, schwitzen tue ich nicht.
Ok, strahlen die Schmerzen in einer anderen Körperregion aus, zum Beispiel in den Rücken?
Nee, das ist tatsächlich nur so, so in der Brust beim Husten. Da tut es weh.
Ok, alles klar. Wie ist Ihr Schlaf?
Ja, also ich schlafe nicht besonders gut, weil ich beim Einschlafen dann eben auch immer viel husten muss.
Und manchmal wache ich dann auch in der Nacht auf und dann muss ich mich auf die Bettkante setzen und dann muss ich auch wieder husten.
Und ja, zudem, also ich habe so ein bisschen eine vergrößerte Prostata und deswegen muss ich schon auch nachts mal zwischendurch auf die Toilette.
Ja, und wenn ich dann huste und auf der Toilette bin, ja, dann ist alles auf einmal und dann kann ich nicht gut wieder einschlafen.
Also die Nächte sind nicht so gut zurzeit.
Wie oft müssen Sie in der Nacht auf die Toilette gehen?
Also einmal, mindestens manchmal auch zweimal, je nachdem, ja.
Ok, verstehe. Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nee, das klappt zum Glück eigentlich ganz gut.
Ok. Haben Sie beim Wasserlassen etwas Ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, zum Beispiel, wenn man im Urinienland ist, ist es immer ein bisschen zu spät.
Ja, zum Beispiel Blut im Urinienland oder etwas Ungewöhnliches.
Nee, also ich bin da auch regelmäßig in Kontrolle.
Also das ist bisher alles gutartig, ja. Das ist nur ein bisschen Vergrößerung.
Aber da gibt es keine Probleme.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ungewollt ab- oder zugenommen?
Ja, also ich wiege mich jetzt zwar nicht regelmäßig, aber eigentlich ist mein Gewicht immer stabil, ja.
Ok. Mussten Sie beim Schlafen mit erhöhtem Oberkörper schlafen?
Also, ja, ich kann da nicht gut schlafen, wenn ich so hoch liege.
Aber ja, zurzeit ist es jetzt eben so in den letzten Tagen, dass ich nicht gut schlafe,
weil ich dann zwischendurch husten muss, sagte ich dann.
Aber einen extra Kissen habe ich jetzt noch nicht.
Oder dass ich mir das Bett hoch stelle.
Ich habe das mal versucht, aber dann rutsche ich nur runter und dann liege ich da unten so zusammengekrümmelt.
Das ist auch nicht gut.
Ok, ich kann das gut verstehen.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelchen chronischen Erkrankungen, wie zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck oder Kranke?
Ja, wäre ja ein Wunder in meinem Alter, wenn man nichts hätte.
Also ich habe natürlich einen hohen Blutdruck.
Und ich habe auch diesen Alterszucker.
Das ist schon seit 15 Jahren.
Jetzt habe ich das schon.
Das ist aber eigentlich ganz gut behandelt.
Ich nehme Metformin morgens und abends.
Und damit ist es eigentlich ganz gut ausgeglichen.
In welcher Dosierung nehmen Sie Metformin-Tabletten?
Oh, was steht da drauf?
Ich glaube, das ist Metformin 500.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Ja, ein bisschen später hat man das festgestellt.
Und dann nehme ich jetzt einen Wetterblocker.
Das habe ich seit 10 Jahren ungefähr, würde ich sagen.
Was nehmen Sie?
Methoprolol heißt das.
In welcher Dosierung nehmen Sie das?
Das ist Methoprolol 25.
Wie oft nehmen Sie das?
Dann nehme ich eine morgens.
Haben Sie noch weitere Erkrankungen?
Ja, wie gesagt, mit der Prostata, das hat man jetzt vor zwei Jahren festgestellt,
dass die ein bisschen vergrößert ist.
Aber das ist wie gesagt in Kontrolle.
Und im Augenblick ist da also nichts, was man tun muss.
Was nehmen Sie gegen Prostata?
Dann nehme ich keine Medikamente.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch weitere Erkrankungen?
Nee, zum Glück nicht, aber ich finde das reicht auch völlig.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf andere Medikamente ein?
Nee, sonst nehme ich eigentlich nie.
Wie gesagt, diese Hustensefte.
Je nachdem, was mir der Apotheker gerade empfiehlt.
Aber das hat jetzt nicht so richtig geholfen.
Okay.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden oder stationär aufgenommen worden?
Ja, also das ist schon ewig lange her.
Da hatte ich mal Probleme mit der Gallenblase.
Und die ist entfernt worden.
Das ist aber schon richtig lange her.
Das ist schon 30 Jahre her.
Noch etwas?
Nee, sonst habe ich noch keine Operation hinter mir.
Okay, das ist klar.
Sie haben ja schon gesagt, dass Sie Hauptstaballergien haben.
Wie äußert sich Hauptstaballergien?
Ja, also überwiegend mit Schnupfen und tränen den Augen.
Ja, auch so ein bisschen Hustenreiz.
Okay. Haben Sie noch weitere Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Nee, sonst kann ich eigentlich mit allem gut klarkommen.
Ich wüsste auch jetzt nicht, dass ich irgendwelche Lebensmittel oder so nicht vertrage.
Ich kann alles essen, was mir schmeckt.
Okay, das ist klar.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, natürlich bin ich gegen Corona geimpft.
In meinem Alter sollte man das ja wirklich machen.
Und ich habe auch die Grippeimpfung mitgemacht.
Und auch diese, was man empfiehlt für alte Leute, mit der Gürtelrose.
Das soll man ja auch sich impfen lassen.
Und das habe ich sogar auch machen lassen.
Ja, alles klar.
Sind Sie gegen Corona geimpft?
Ja, aber dieses Jahr noch nicht.
Und letztes Jahr glaube ich auch nicht.
Aber die Jahre davor.
Viermal oder vielleicht sogar fünfmal bin ich geimpft.
Alles klar.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit beim Ausland?
Im Ausland? Nee, wir waren die ganze Zeit zu Hause.
Rachen Sie, Herr Kaiser?
Ja, natürlich rauche ich.
Ich rauche auch ein bisschen viel.
Das kann ich auch nicht gut aufgeben.
Wie viele Zigaretten rauchen Sie?
Ja, schon ein bisschen mehr als ein Päckchen.
Ein Päckchen?
Ja, schon ein bisschen mehr auch.
Wie viele Zigaretten rauchen Sie?
Ach ja, das zählt natürlich nicht.
So ein Päckchen reicht über fünf Tage.
Vier Päckchen reichen über fünf Tage.
Nee, fünf Päckchen reichen nicht über vier Tage.
Fünf?
Ja, also 25 Zigaretten am Tag ungefähr.
Wieviele Jahre haben Sie geraucht?
Lange, lange, lange.
Ich habe auch nicht immer so viele geraucht.
Bei der Arbeit ging das nicht so gut.
Da habe ich vielleicht ein bisschen weniger geraucht.
Aber jetzt bin ich auch schon lange im Ruhestand.
Also, dass ich so viel rauche, das ist bestimmt schon 20 Jahre.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nee, ich habe nur einen Laster.
Aber Alkohol trinke ich tatsächlich gar nicht.
Ok, das ist genau.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Drogen? Nein, nein, also ich in meinem Alter, nein, keine Drogen.
Ok, ich verstehe.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen?
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Ich habe ja gesagt, mein Bruder, das macht mir so ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen.
Der hat halt Lungenkrebs.
Und ja, da habe ich jetzt natürlich so ein bisschen Angst.
Ok, ich kann Sie gut verstehen.
Es tut mir leid.
Ist Ihr Vater gesund?
Ja, die leben natürlich schon lange nicht mehr.
Meine Eltern, überlegen Sie mal, wie alt ich bin.
Mein Vater, der hatte vor Jahren einen Herzinfarkt.
Aber der ist auch relativ alt geworden.
Der war weit über 80.
80, ok, das ist genau.
Ist Ihre Mutter gesund?
Die lebt natürlich auch nicht mehr.
Die müsste ja jetzt auch schon ewig alt sein.
Nein, die Eltern leben nicht mehr.
Woran ist sie gestorben? Darf ich fragen?
Das weiß ich gar nicht so genau.
Also Altersschwäche oder so.
Irgendwann hat sie halt nicht mehr gelebt.
Können Sie bitte wiederholen?
Ich glaube nicht, dass sie eine schwere Erkrankung hatte.
Sie ist einfach an Altersschwäche gestorben.
Ok, alles klar.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Sie haben ja schon gesagt, dass Sie Rentner sind.
Ja, zum Glück schon lange.
Ich bin Rentner und das ist auch gut so.
Ich habe in einer Bank gearbeitet, viele Jahre.
Banken, alles klar.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ja.
Ok, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, die sind natürlich schon erwachsen.
Die sind schon lange aus dem Haus.
Aber ja, wir haben zwei Kinder.
Ok, sind Sie gesund?
Ja, so viel ich weiß, sind die fit.
Die sind ja auch noch jung.
Sie leben mit Ihrem Mann, habe ich recht?
Mit meiner Frau.
Ich bin ein Mann.
Also ich lebe mit meiner Frau.
Alles klar.
Herr Kaiser, ich habe alle meine Fragen gestellt.
Wir sind mit unserem Gespräch fertig.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Sie haben ja so viel gefragt und ich habe Ihnen jetzt eine Menge erzählt.
Ich will jetzt natürlich nur wissen, was man gegen den Husten tun kann.
Und wie man das ausschließen kann, dass es Krebs ist.
Das ist mir wichtig.
Ich kann Sie gut verstehen.
Bitte versuchen Sie ruhig zu bleiben.
Im Moment können wir nichts ausschließen.
Bevor ich Ihnen etwas Genueres sagen kann,
brauche ich alle Informationen und Untersuchungen.
Zuerst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Danach Blut abnehmen.
Und eine Röntgenuntersuchung des Brutkorbs durchführen.
Ja, das ist auch lange nicht gemacht worden.
Sie müssen alle Ergebnisse abwarten.
Sobald wir alle Ergebnisse haben, können wir alles ausführlich besprechen.
Und gemeinsam das weitere Vorgehen planen.
Das klingt gut.
Danke schön.
Vielen Dank.
Bitte warten Sie hier.
Ich komme gleich.
Wunderbar. Danke schön.
Darf ich fragen?
Ja, klar.
Haben Sie zu Hause Schimmel bemerkt?
Schimmel?
Nein, wir müssen aufpassen wegen der Hausstauballergie.
Deswegen rüften wir immer gut.
Schimmelbildung gibt es nicht in der Wohnung.
Haben Sie vielleicht Haustiere?
Nein, Haustiere haben wir nicht.
Sehr gut. Danke.
Darf ich fragen?
Ja, natürlich.
Ist Ihnen die Pfeifenatmung aufgefallen?
Pfeifen? Nein, nicht wirklich.
Und hatten Sie früher Beschwerden?
Diese Beschwerden sind erstmalig?
Natürlich habe ich im Laufe meines Lebens schon mehrfach Rüsten gehabt.
Aber so lange dauert es und so viel Schleim produziert.
Diese Art Not kenne ich nicht.
Das ist neu.
Aber der Rüsten könnte früher vielleicht mehr als drei Monate gedauert haben?
Nein, so lange hat es nie gedauert.
Nein, das war immer nach zwei Wochen.
Drei Wochen war der Rüsten weg.
Es ist jetzt auch komisch, dass das überhaupt nicht weggeht.
Danke.
Darf ich fragen?
Haben Sie Schwellungen an Ihren Beinen bemerkt?
Meine Beine?
Nein, das fällt einem ja auf, wenn die Socken knallt.
Da habe ich aber eigentlich nicht aufgefallen.
Darf ich?
Ja, natürlich. Alle dürfen.
Gibt es besondere Zeit, dass Sie diese Rüsten bekommen?
Also, nachts ist es schlecht.
Morgen, wenn ich aufwache, muss ich auch erst lange husten.
Und dann, ja, zum Abend wird es dann nochmal ein bisschen schlechter.
Aber ich muss eigentlich den ganzen Tag ständig ein bisschen husten.
Treiben Sie Sport, wenn Sie kalte Wetter treiben?
Haben Sie Husten schlechter?
Ja, also richtig aktiv Sport machen.
Ich bin noch viel mit meinem Fahrrad unterwegs.
Und ja, wenn es mal bergauf geht, dann muss ich schon vielleicht ein bisschen mehr husten.
Aber eigentlich ist es eher an der frischen Luft ein bisschen angenehmer.
Aber ich bin jetzt natürlich auch kein Rennradfahrer oder so,
ich fahre nur mal was, was ich so in der Stadt zum einkaufen oder zur Post oder irgendwie sowas.
Dann nehme ich halt das Fahrrad.
Aber ich fahre jetzt keine anstrengenden Stricken.
Danke schön.
Gibt es Neues bei Ihnen? Ungewöhnliches oder Neues?
Zum Beispiel neue Blume oder irgendwelche Sachen zu Hause?
Ja, in meinem Alter wissen Sie, wir sind froh, dass wir nicht mehr so viel Zeug um uns herum haben.
Wir kaufen auch nichts Neues.
Also eigentlich wüsste ich jetzt nicht, dass wir irgendwie neue Möbel oder neue Sachen oder irgendwas neu haben.
Ist alles wie immer.
Noch eine Frage. Ist die Husten verschlimmert, besonders in der Nacht, oder?
Ob der Husten verschlimmert ist in der Nacht?
Ja.
Ja, das habe ich ja gesagt, dass ich nachts oft aufwache, weil ich dann Husten muss.
Und dass ich am Morgen, wenn ich dann aufwache, eben auch erst mal Husten muss.
Morgen husten mit Schleim oder Ausruf?
Immer viel Schleim.
Ist Ihr Gewicht stabil? Ich möchte wissen, ob Sie in der letzten Zeit ungewollt ab- oder so genommen?
Hat er gefragt, aber der Patient hat das verneint.
Ja, glaube ich, haben Sie keine Fieber.
Dr. Satishi, Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn Sie so weit sind?
Bitte, ich bin bereit.
Sie sind bereit, ja, dann, ich glaube, wir haben jetzt viele Fragen gestellt.
Ich hatte eigentlich das Gefühl, dass er sehr komplett gefragt hat.
Und jetzt habe ich mich gewundert, dass noch so viele Nachfragen kamen.
Gut, ich weiß nicht, ob Sie Zeit hatten oder das geschafft haben, neben dem Notieren noch so ein bisschen mitzuhören, was die anderen gefragt haben.
Jetzt schauen wir. So, Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch, los geht's.
Okay. Schönen guten Tag, Frau Obererstin. Es geht um, ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Es geht um Herrn Werner Kallseid, der 74 Jahre alt ist.
Bei einer Größe von 1,81 Meter wiegt er aktuell 90 Kilogramm.
Er stellt sich bei Usfa wegen seit drei Monaten bestehenden starken Tussis und Düsne.
Diese Beschwerden sind meistens beim Husten aufgetreten.
Und die Düsne sind seit ein bis zwei Tagen stärker geworden.
Okay.
Es gibt meiner Meinung nach keine bestimmten Auslöser.
Unserer Patient hat eine Halsstaballergie. Aber es gibt keine bekannten Asthma.
Es gibt eine weisse und schleimige Schkotung und leichtes Toraxschmerzen.
Der Schmerzcharakter ist als Dürkend. Schmerzintensität wurde mit 5 und 10 bewertet.
Die Düsne und Brustschmerzen sind langsam aufgetreten, aber im Laufe der Zeit sehr stark geworden.
Es besteht keine Ausstrahlung.
Die Fragen nach Odinophagie, Gynore, Nose erbrochen wurden verneint.
Die Einnahme von einer Hustensaft hat keine Linderung der Symptome gebracht.
Die Fieber, Schüttelfrost und Nachschweiß wurden auch verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese ergab Hustenbedingte insomnie in Form von Anschlafstörungen und Durchschlafstörungen.
Die Medizinische Vorgeschichte hat eine benigte Prostatehyperplasie.
Er hat eine Hauptstoffallergie, die sich mit Renokonjunktivitis äußert.
Unser Patient ist vollständig geimpft, insbesondere gegen Herpes, Doster, Corona und Grippe.
Er schaut seit 20 Jahren 45 Zigaretten täglich.
45?
Nein, 25 Zigaretten.
25 Zigaretten, Alkoholkonsum und Drogenkonsum wurden verneint.
Der Vater des Patienten litt an einem Myokadinfakt.
Der Bruder des Patienten wegen einer Lungenkarcinom operiert worden.
Er ist Rentner.
Früher arbeitet er als Banker.
Wo arbeitet er? In einer Bank?
In einer Bank, im Geldinstitut.
Er ist verheiratet, hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Er lebt mit seiner Frau.
Die anonystischen Angaben sollten anheften.
Eine exzerserbierte Asthma-Gronkhalle.
Was könnte es differenzial diagnostisch sein?
Die Pneumonie ist in Bezug auf Pneumonie.
Die Pneumonie kann auch eine Herzinfizienz oder Herzrhythmusstörungen sein.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Ich bestimme zuerst die Vitalparameter.
Danach ausführlich körperliche Untersuchungen.
Worauf achten Sie besonders bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich den Fokus auf Lungen.
Bei der Osmophobe prüfe ich Lungengeräusche.
Ich prüfe, ob mögliche feinbläsige Geräuschbrummen,
die man verliegt, um die Pneumonie auszuschließen.
Bei der Inspektion kontrolliere ich Cyanose und Kapilloführung.
Natürlich untersuche ich die Mundhöhle.
Und Pneumonien und Pneumonien.
Was machen Sie noch diagnostisch?
Nach der Untersuchung würde ich eine Blutuntersuchung durchführen.
Und eine Untersuchung des Thorax.
Was lassen Sie im Labor bestimmen?
Im Labor sollte ein großes Blutbild, CRP, Nieren- und Lebewerte, Elektrolyte bestimmt werden.
Auch die Dämere ist notwendig.
Was machen Sie weiter an Untersuchung?
Im Labor können wir Blutgasanalyse bestimmen.
Ich würde eine Diagnose durchführen.
Und noch etwas.
Hier kommt noch ein Hinweis auf eine weitere Laboruntersuchung.
Das ist auch nicht uninteressant, dass man Sputum kontrolliert.
Um Pneumonie auszuschließen, würde ich Sputumkült und Untersuchung durchführen.
Das sind jetzt die möglichen Untersuchungen.
Die Röntgenuntersuchungen haben Sie auch gesagt.
Bei unklaren Bebefunden im Röntgen würde ich natürlich Thorax CT veranlassen.
Was kommt bei Ihren Untersuchungen raus?
Wie entwickelt sich der Zustand des Patienten?
Wie würden Sie therapeutisch vorgehen?
Wenn ich meine Verdachtstheatmose bestätigen würde, würde ich zuerst Sauerstoff geben.
Je nach Blutgasanalyse.
Dann würde ich mit Salbutamol und Glycocorticoid veranlassen.
Über die Maske.
Bei der Infektion würde ich die Antibiotika der Therapie anleiten.
Dann schauen wir uns das mit den Patienten an.
Vielen Dank.
Das ging doch ruckzuck.
Sie haben konsequent gefragt.
Es kamen noch ein paar Spezialfragen von den Kollegen.
Die alle wahrscheinlich ihre Verdachtstheatmose im Kopf hatten.
Ich habe nur einen einzigen Schönheitsfehler in der ganzen Geschichte.
Sie haben sehr oft gefragt, ob sie etwas anderes einfallen lassen.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie blaue Düppen haben?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Können Sie nachts gut schlafen?
Ich habe immer die Frage immer verantwortlich.
Es ist schwierig, weil man eine Checkliste im Kopf vor sich hat.
Sie haben sehr souverän Ihren Bericht abgegeben.
Sie haben vollständig wiedergegeben, was der Patient gesagt hat.
Ich habe immer die Frage immer verantwortlich.
Bei den Eltern ist es immer krass, wenn man einen 74-Jährigen fragt.
Wenn ich an mich selber denke, denke ich, dass da eine Vorerkrankung war.
Woran die Eltern gestorben sind.
Sie haben sehr schön an dich übergeleitet.
Sie haben gesagt, jetzt habe ich noch Fragen hierzu und dazu.
Ich habe immer die Frage immer verantwortlich.
Ich denke mal, Sie haben sich sehr gut geschlagen.
Sie können sehr entspannt in Ihre Prüfung gehen.
Ich danke Ihnen für die Aufnahme des Patienten.